[Music]
his own location in Canada and I gotta
say I'm kind of loving this crap can you
like that Nance
it's actually for a film that I'm
shooting out here in the wilderness near
Winnipeg Canada which by the way is like
a vacation compared to my last attempt
to become an American Ninja Warrior this
was my chance at redemption after fire
in the water last year I was determined
my ego was on the line this is out win
this is our you know anniversary of
sorts I was ya just competed in
Cleveland last year I did okay made it
about halfway through I think I'm ready
to try some yeah you are who wants to go
swimming in Las Vegas Wow
today's challenge is as tough as it gets
this is the Las Vegas finals course
which means only the best of the best
will make it to this level the Las Vegas
finals start Monday on NBC warming me up
as veteran ninja Natalie Duran
[Laughter]
okay well redemption not quite yet after
changing into superb clothes the moment
of truth okay last words before I go
have fun with it that's really the key
of it
Cameron Mathison known for his
incredible hair and great physique the
question many have Akbar he's that
functional or does it just look good and
his hair looks immaculate he has said he
does not want to get it wet you know
what he's doing the Cirque de Soleil
he's using those hips doing the lobby
release down Wow Cameron you could never
let us down most of us could never have
even grabbed the very first bar and you
tried so hard I did I tried so hard I
was holding on for dear life I literally
couldn't feel my arms I had to let go
Nancy kilt me I know it's so much
tougher than it looks alright so the big
question is will you try again can the
third time be the charm
you know I will there is no quitting me
Nancy I will be back and I will get this
[Music]